hey everyone welcome to live coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and today we're going
to keep working on that search page that
we've been working on for a while now
but we're gonna move on to something new
we're gonna work on the sorting which we
just started to get into at the end of
yesterday stream so now I'd like to
spend a little bit of time and try to
actually get it working I'm going to
start out let's see I'll just check in
analytics make sure we had some people
in here before I start out and give my
my usual opening statement I think the
analytics is a little bit behind this I
know we have more people waiting but for
those of you who are new we in this
sorry so if you're new in this stream
you get to watch me do my daily work as
a front-end developer for a small
university I don't rehearse this
beforehand so there will be mistakes and
that's kind of the point is that you get
to see a full-time developer make
mistakes and work through those mistakes
my hope is that if you're new to web
development or to programming in general
you'll see that it's okay to make
mistakes you know everybody makes
mistakes at least I do a lot and you
know you just work through and you keep
going and we also have some very
experienced developers that watch as
well and they can provide some useful
help in the live chat so if you can
watch it live
and ask questions in the chat you'll get
some good answers you know most of the
time we break everything up by Pomodoro
sessions so Pomodoro session is 25
minutes so we'll do 25 minutes of code
we'll take a five-minute break and we'll
chat in the live chat a bit
and then 25 minutes of code and then at
the end of the show that's when we do
most of the question and answers so if
you ask a question please be patient and
we'll get to it at the end of the show
the show is available to watch as a
recording you know right after the
stream so you know at any point in the
future if you want to come back to it or
you can't catch the whole thing now you
know don't worry about it you can just
watch later on whenever you have a
chance okay cool so it looks like we
have our normal number of viewers in
here now so I'm gonna switch screens so
y'all can see what I see we will be
working in our search j/s file if you
check the description for this video
there will be a link to the github repo
and the github repo is up to date let's
double check and make sure we'll do a
get pool right everything's up to date
here
I always like to start out my work by
doing a git pull to make sure there
aren't any changes that haven't you know
made their way down locally yet it's a
pain to start working and then realize
that you don't have all the code I'm
also going to bring the Pomodoro timer
over here and we're going to start it
and I'm gonna start the end rock server
as well and then that way you all can
see what I'm seeing on my screen and you
can click around and test the site on
your own so here's the end Rock link
coming into the live chat right now and
alright John Hanson and the chap
mentioned that the chat is saved yeah
second I saw at least yesterday's video
had the chat saved so if you watch the
replay you will be able to see what's
going on the chat I think that's really
nice I mean I've tried my best to try to
read out things in the chat but I know I
missed something sometimes so now you'll
be able to keep up with everything
that's going on the chat it for those of
you who can't watch live I think that
will really help you to be able to
understand you know kind of the
back-and-forth between you
those of you in the in the live chat now
okay
rut Rajesh I see your question we'll get
to that on the first break okay so if
you could just hang on for a little bit
at the end of this twenty five minutes
I'll get to that question if anyone the
live chat wants to address the question
of how to start out learning to code and
react you know please put the answers in
there now for Ruud Rajesh or Rajesh I'm
sorry I'm not sure how to pronounce that
okay then Nicky says there was a pull
request for the search page so let's
check that out Melvin so the first part
may just be taking care of this pull
request
okay let's see the notifications okay
let's check that out so if you're not
familiar with how to manage projects
through github this will be kind of a
good you know good little intro to
merging pull requests so we get a pull
request in and whatever usually you have
a description if somebody submits pull
requests in the description then not
it's probably not likely to get merged
so updated State in an immutable way in
the only change handler for checkboxes
only called creates search sites after
set state is complete okay cool so Niki
I'm not gonna read these right now on
the chat I don't I don't know why I
didn't see this PR you know now I
remember when the notification came up
for this and I was at a meeting this
morning for a few hours so that's
probably why I didn't remember it after
the meeting ended
so let's now that we read what it's
about I always go in and check the files
to see what changed exactly so on the
left hand side this is what was there
before the right hand side are the
changes so here's our handle change
function before and now before we were
reading the variable for checkboxes
sorry I'm not feeling well so if I'm
coughing or sneezing I apologize in
advance so let's see just a teeth on
search alright so now I'm not as worried
about explaining what we did cuz we did
this on a stream so let's go
okay so we're getting the previous state
so when you go to do set state you you
can have get the previous state here you
don't usually need it but it does come
in handy sometimes and now we're
returning checkboxes previous state
check boxes okay Nikki that's a great
idea now I remember you saying that in
the live chat and for whatever reason I
didn't implement it then but just to
explain what's going on here
so we're returning check boxes so we're
gonna set the state of check boxes and
the new state of check boxes is going to
be everything from the old State
combined with one of the check boxes
being checked so whatever one we just
clicked on will be checked okay so you
see these three dots in front of here so
this is already all the check boxes here
and we're just combining it so it's a
way to combine in this case what do we
have an object yeah it's a combined
objects really easily in a concise way
what is that the spread operator is that
what that's called
it's an es6 thing so I believe it's
spread operator let me know in the live
chat if that's the wrong name for it but
if you look up ESX spread operator then
you should be able to find a lot more
info on on how to use this and when it's
appropriate to use it all right and then
after that we're gonna create the search
types and if you're not sure what that's
doing it's it's okay it's just calling
off a function and then this function is
actually going to run the search so if
you check out the stream yesterday you
can learn a lot more about what these
functions are doing but for now just
know that
once the checkbox is checked the last
thing that's going to happen is it's
actually going to search okay so I am
getting confirmation that it was the
spread operator so that is the right
word for it so it's it's really really
useful so if you find yourself needing
to do things with with objects with
combining objects and things check it
out alright wonderful you know that Niki
this looks great
I'm not I'm not even gonna test this out
first I'm just going to merge it because
it's really evident what this does and I
think we're safe to just merge it you
don't always want to just merge
something if it's a small change like
this and really you know kind of
well-done and obvious to see what's
happening
I'm usually okay with just merging it
but anything really bigger than this
you'll want to test first and I do have
some videos where I've tested things so
if you go if you go back and search
through my videos and find one on like
merging pool requests
that'll I think I go through the whole
process of testing I'd like to make a
video on on my own channel which there's
a link in description for my own channel
so I'd like to make a short to the point
video on merging for people that don't
want to sift through all the hours of
live streams and they just wanted me to
get to the point I'm gonna make a video
for those for those people in for people
who just don't have time to watch the
stream so I think I'm gonna make that
somewhat soon still watch out for that
I'll tell you all when I when I do make
it if you're interested so now since I
I've decided I do want to merge this all
I have to do is go here and go to merge
pull request nice I'm going to confirm
the merge now you can do you thinks
through the command line but this is in
my opinion the fastest way to do it if
you know you want to merge it right away
I always leave a comment
I always want to show my appreciation
for those of you that do submit pull
requests and if you're maintaining a
repository and github I also recommend
that you show your appreciation and
encouragement for those who who do
submit pull requests I know for me like
especially when I was starting out it
could be very very intimidating to
submit pull requests and you know kind
of being ignored or having some harsh
words can really did demoralize you so
just be aware of that you know when
you're a maintainer new people
especially like really look up to you
and if they care enough about your
project to want to you know submit a
pull request they may have put a lot of
time into it even if it doesn't seem
like it because if they're beginner it
may taken a long time for them to do
even something basic so you know a word
of encouragement from you could really
you know kind of give them that
motivation to increase their skills but
you know a mean word could kind of crush
their spirit you know they may be the
last straw for them so you know I'm not
saying that you're entirely responsible
for their their whole career but you
know just be aware of that for me on
both sides of it that's just you know
kind of what I've seen ok we need to now
pull those changes down oops let me make
this bigger I'm sorry about that
that was so small before all right so
we're gonna do a get pool again and
those changes that we just merged in on
github are now local in our search that
jazz file so let's scroll down just to
see handle change what's going on
it's not showing me it don't say let me
just open it up again
there we are sometimes it doesn't
automatically change for me so I have to
reopen the file but now you can see that
here's all the changes and definitely
want to verify that everything still
works I mean based on what we saw in the
code it should still work but it's good
to get to try it out so let's go with
good to know we have a theology major
wonderful let's make sure that you know
we have Department there's nobody with
four faculty there we go okay it was
working wonderful
okay great so these are working now and
alright here's the next step then let's
now we have a check boxes you know
working we definitely want to add more
check boxes but for now we're just kind
of getting everything working and then
we can fill in you know however many
check boxes or sorting things that we
need later on we still don't have all
the data over so I don't really know how
many check boxes we need until I get all
that data over so now I'd like to go
back to where we left off at yesterday
with our sorting I believe where did we
put this sorting they we are so we have
this function here it's a sort by type
and let's just briefly review what we've
done so for those of you that watched
yesterday you know just bear with me as
I repeat this because I'm sure there are
people that that didn't see it so we're
gonna call this sort by function
whenever a user clicks on I guess it'll
be will be a drop-down or radio I
haven't I don't know exactly what kind
of input we'll do either a radio or a
drop-down so I guess so let's just think
about that for the next few minutes as
I'm going over this and let me know what
you think would be better for this type
of thing so first we're gonna do a check
to see if the data that we've gotten is
equal to 100 so what we're getting data
from wordpress from the wordpress api
they the max amount of posts that we can
get from the wordpress api is 100
so we know if we've gotten 100 posts and
we want to do a sort we need to actually
do another search and do the sorting in
WordPress and then get the sorted data
you know because if our search would
normally return 500 posts and we only
have a hundred right now we haven't
gotten the rest of them and then we sort
those hundred then when it's not going
to give the result that the user really
expects or needs right if it's
alphabetical you know and we're starting
with a there's going to be a lot of
other stuff that starts with a that is
in that you know other 400 posts that we
haven't even gotten yet so the sorting
is going to be messed up and we need all
right Nikki what's the end grog link all
right I posted it once let's post it
again sorry about that Nikki so that's
why we have that check so that may or
may not make sense I think I did a
better job of explaining it yesterday
because we were actually getting the
data and things but basically we need
that check to make sure that we we do
end up returning the correct data to the
user the other check we're going to make
is if the data equals zero if the data
equals zero then this probably means
that a search has not occurred yet so
it's very I don't even know if it's
possible the search would not have
occurred yet and the user is actually
clicking these sorting things and
there's actually something in the the
search bar but I threw that in there
just in case we may be able to remove
this if as we build this out we realized
that this is an impossible scenario
we'll remove it but better safe than
sorry on that it's just a little extra
thing so in any case we just do another
we do another search so first we set the
state
sort by to our type so this is the type
of sorting that we're passing in and
then we do this this search so we
haven't added in like are sorting right
so we need to do that today else so if
the data if the number of posts we have
in in-state is greater than 1 greater
than 0 but less than 100 then we come
down here and we just do a sort on the
data we already have and we don't make
another API call which will definitely
save resources it'll save time it'll
save the users bandwidth ok so this is a
data sorted okay and then we just
changed the order of the data then state
and since this is react we change state
everything gets rear-ended so the user
will immediately see all that data that
they were seeing before but now it's
going to be sorted the way they want it
so let's let's build out this sorting
function and I think we had did we find
an example at the end of the stream I
can't remember I don't think I pasted
one the copy and paste one I mainly
remember trying to find an example then
I apologize again like my mind is just
fuzzy I'm definitely starting to get
sick so I'm gonna do my best in this
stream but I know I'm gonna mess some
things up
what is this resources oh okay
now I remember we searched in here I
thought that I had some sorting
happening in here
but then after searching through this I
realized that I didn't have sorting did
we have sorting what project did we have
it in all right let me check one other
project if it's not in this other one
then we'll come up with it on our own
but we could potentially save us a lot
of time if we can just use something
we've used before bulletin
I think the bulletin react project
possibly has it let's see
who
not there
okay all right so we're doing some
searching here okay cool so we're doing
a filter by dates but I don't think
we're doing this client-side this
project is still unfinished okay so
let's let's just go over here then and
I'm trying to think of so we're gonna
have four different types of sorting you
know what I remember where I've done
this before
I'm pretty sure that I've done this this
exact type of sorting before I just
can't remember if I did a client-side or
server-side so let me find it okay
let's see where they did in reducers
give a set sorting alright shouldn't out
sort by
okay maybe I did the sorting in the
component then so this is a project
that's using react and redux so if
you're not familiar with redux then some
of this will probably look really weird
all these projects that I've been
searching through are completely
open-source they're available on my
github repo or my github profile so you
can check them out if you want to know
more about it this was one that I did
for the Udacity react nanodegree this
was project two so let's see the views
let's see if I have this and you sold my
bringing in the sorting sort great okay
side nav sort by I know of another one
yes yes all right cool all right so I
found it yeah Wow I knew I had done this
before with react so we're not using
Redux in our current project so the way
we implement this will be slightly
different so instead of getting values
from redux we're gonna get our values
directly from state it should be fine
the search page is just one page I'm
okay with just using state instead of
using Redux
we may find down the line that we have a
lot more going on and maybe we should
use Redux we can always switch over that
at that time or something like Redux
you know something you know built-in
with Apollo so we're doing we are doing
some filtering here that we don't need
to do and our project but here's the
actual sort so we have a switch
statement and this allows us to sort for
multiple different types of sorting all
which is one dot sort I think this is
what we'll go with
this is a lot cleaner than having lots
of different
functions to sort you know we just can
have one so the switch statement takes
in this prop sort by which in our case
will be this state sort by well even use
the same subconsciously I think I
remember this because I even use the
same name for it but in the case by
score lowest we have dates so that date
will actually be one so we can do date
oldest so in this case we're returning
aid timestamp minus B dot timestamp okay
and that will that'll sort this by the
oldest date so the oldest date is going
to be the like less than right so dates
being like just a big long number okay
so that's the default here so we're
gonna have to return a default we'll
figure out what the default ought to be
what the user will expect I'm thinking
newest first might be what what's
expected so we'll have to maybe we'll
have to think about that and then
replace what needs replaced and then
we'll try out our sorting okay let's see
okay so right reg s okay well we had a
question before that Wow there were some
of you were here a half hour early so
Divya says already waiting last night
you left at some place to explain please
explain that again okay let me know
Divya what I was explaining so I did go
back and explain some of what we were
doing yesterday but I may not have
explained exactly what you needed so
please let me know and I'll try to
explain
and then Rajesh says I'm new to react
can you suggest me a way to start coding
and react I'm sure you've probably
gotten some other answers down lower in
the
live-chat so sorry if I'm repeating but
the react documentation is a nice place
to start the if you want to pay for a
course the Udacity react nano degree I
took that course myself I learned a lot
from it so I think that's a good one to
do I think who is it west west boss I
have never done any of his courses with
w es BOS okay so look that up he does a
lot of courses like I said I haven't
done any so I can't say from personal
experience but a lot of people really
like his courses I'm gonna have to try
stuff out one day you know just because
I've heard so many good things about it
those resources should be pretty decent
to get you started I'm sure there's a
lot of other good resources out there I
just haven't seen them yet see a lot a
lot of you were saying hi so hey Amit
says write some code that was at the
beginning when I was going over my intro
so I haven't actually written that much
code yet so we're gonna get to some code
sometimes that's how it is though
programming is a lot of thinking and
looking things up and reviewing code you
know what I actually typed that much
some days we type a lot some days we
don't let's see more of you saying hi
I'm not gonna go through every one
individually but I do see all of your
names so hello everyone
the the garv man I'm messing up his name
bar Bhargav bah aaargh av really sorry
I'm sure messing up your name let me
know I should pronounce it says why
don't you try at Google my bro
I'm not exactly sure you mean like try
to work at Google I did apply to a job
at Google in Pittsburgh a while ago so
that would be cool but I'm sure a lot of
really really good developers apply it
to any jobs at Google so that'd be a
long shot for me
okay so Ahmad also recommends West bus
so the courses react for beginners so
thank you for that Ahmad
all right so divya says start with react
tutorials from net ninja and learn
Codecademy oh you know what i forgot
about learning code academy
that's a youtube channel I did learn a
lot about react from that YouTube
channel and about get and a lot of other
things the channels not updated
regularly anymore so some of what you
see in those videos will be a little
outdated but it's it's like
fundamentally still pretty good so so
yeah definitely check out that that
channel 1-0 says reduce mic volume is my
mic is it too loud I mean I'd hate to I
mean for all I said if it's too loud
then maybe just turn down the video cuz
I don't want to turn it down and then
mess it up for everybody else so let me
know I mean if everybody's saying it's
too loud then maybe I'll turn it down
but I'd rather have it too loud for some
and then give them the ability to turn
it down on their own machines because if
it's too low for people you can't you
know they can't do anything about that
okay so it didn't make it through
everything in the live chat I will come
back and finish up with all the
questions in the live chat
after after we finish up with this
Pomodoro session so now let's grab this
sort let's see we need this too
Wow am I actually doing the map as well
yeah I am well okay all right so where
we get our swords let's put it here okay
so this state data sword
okay so we're sorting that we're saving
it to the variable sort of data and
instead of this props we want this state
sort by and actually we do we need this
states whereby no we don't we don't need
to grab it here because we already we're
pulling in the type so let's just get
the type it'll save us a few characters
so we can probably refactor this a good
bit after we get finished with it but
let's just get it working first so our
cases here are gonna be different I
don't want to go with these all caps I
mean that's that was the way to do it
with with Redux but I don't want it
hopes what did I do
I don't want to do it like that here so
this is vote score so we don't want
those four we want
give an alphabetical order so actually
let's just change our let's make sure
we're actually getting a timestamp with
this data or what it is yeah we are
getting we're getting all of the data
back right okay let me look here we are
okay so here's the data that we're
getting in the format all right so
here's the date let's make sure that
there aren't any other dates that would
be more appropriate to use okay so
here's the day should we change the date
then probably we're probably going to
need to manipulate this date first but
at least we know we can we can get that
date and then title is what we use for
the alphabetical order stuff so title
rendered okay
this is gonna be a dots everywhere
instead of timestamp we're just gonna
say date for now well we're probably
gonna have to change this but we'll just
save it there for now we may need to
yeah I'm not gonna get ahead of myself
let's just keep going here so we don't
have a vote score but we won't need to
make this let's go with I don't rendered
and then let's just put these in so I
remember what it is so instead of us who
are lowest this will be alpha
that's ending and this is gonna be alpha
descending is our default I don't want
that to be our default that will change
it but not right now
date by oldest just call this dates
newest date all the stateless
okay and this is the type
this should be outside the if-statement
okay because no matter what we need to
change the sort that's we're tight okay
actually
all right I got some other ideas for how
this can be refactored buzz I need to
focus and not keep getting ahead of
myself
let's see it's for now I just want to
return is this this is gonna save to
data right this sort data and then it's
gonna set State okay so we should be
able to just check this as long as we
check data to see if it's doing anything
I want to check and see if any of these
will work as is I don't have high hopes
that they will oh let's say Nikki in the
live chat has something for I so day two
UNIX epoch due date for ashore I sewed a
string oh cool awesome so let's let's do
that now
so within
who
I guess we just have to do it like this
like so
yeah
thank sneaky so that we might get the
day to work right now so let's test that
so what we need to do is call this sore
bye
so let's see yes we're gonna let's
manually call this and actually let's
yeah let's go use this states sort by
okay and then this way we'll be able to
change values and state in in our dev
tools
so let's go was it a tortoise can you
fetch the search term let's just put it
after here for now what was that sort
was this sort by was that what we called
it
yeah sort by okay let's try it
alright so we say before in that part of
that front let me just go up here
alright only 53 awesome I'm not actually
displaying the date you know it's :
reacts
okay so here's okay so nothing happened
with our search type so that's no good
because it should have this sort by date
oldest should have taken type and it
should have used it to set the state so
that's no good
and data
hmmm let's change some things up to
oh you're right sort by I didn't change
there that's good all right so let's go
with
date
all right let's change this up a little
bit so we can really test it the way I'm
doing it now is is a little silly okay
let's take this out from now okay
it's not except tight for now
and let's display let's go down here to
our display for components and name
title rendered item type okay so right
here let's put
dates so now we'll actually be able to
see the date in our results area so we
can see the date here not very pretty
but it works so right now
[Music]
and then see if
all right so it looks like this is
giving us newest first let's let's
change this so we did say date oldest is
a new list you're gonna switch anything
no because we're not actually firing
that off again all right let's change
that
are we getting
[Music]
alright let's actually put in our to our
toggle here I think it'll make it a lot
easier to test I'm just I'm checking the
live chat here for a second
to make sure I'm not missing anything
okay alright so let's put in wonder what
I did for that project that we were just
looking at
oh I remember I didn't have a drop down
or anything I just had a list and you
could just click on it okay
all right let's see oopss know what I
want I want material UI next there we go
now I only have 8 minutes not sure I'm
gonna be able to get to set in 8 minutes
all right I'm not I'm not gonna be able
to do that in 8 minutes we're gonna have
to hard code some of this so that we can
make sure that it works so let's go
let's hard code dates actually this
let's do and ok and then here we will
put the type and we'll go date not like
that
date which I date newest
okay so swear by his date newest and so
now let's try biology and let's see 3 1
1 18-49 ok cool that does look like it's
it's in it's showing the newest first
now let's try oldest see if that makes a
difference
you know it didn't so we just changed
this
oops what happened yes sit stay
oh you know what actually that shouldn't
even matter because we're not we're not
getting it from state anymore
I was refresh
yeah I'm definitely seeing no difference
what am i doing
well let's try this one
food
yeah my eyes are sorting not working
go there so the second one and would be
sorted let's see if there's any
difference ID so we're 50 to 59 55 to 59
55
yeah it looks like there's no difference
in this sordid one
okay so why is there no difference
let's look up a sort make sure we're
using that correctly so get an MD n this
is a great resource so let's see how
they're using sort so it looks like
mansoura automatically sorts
what's it automatically sorting into
okay so it's up in a corner
automatically
okay and then you have our default okay
all right so let's see if it was less
than V I someone could he return
yeah this is this is how we're using it
now look at these examples
[Music]
[Music]
maybe the problem is here let's do this
sorted data
yes
I'm gonna change this to date oldest oh
yeah alright last time I'm gonna test it
before I go back to the live chat
just give it a refresh just to be sure
no but it's 53 52 59 55
it's it's kind of weird
all right let me check the live chat
there are a few suggestions here okay
michael says maybe try less than instead
of - nikki says the return value for
that sort function has to be a number it
has three options that it takes into
account negative zero positive okay all
right so let's yeah I'm gonna end it now
partly because I'm just I'm really
feeling super tired so I'm I'm probably
gonna leave work soon but basically at
this point to get this working I would
probably just do some testing to see
whether or not what I have in here is
actually even the right stuff so I might
do like even just tests in the console I
guess to see if these sorts work like
individually I suppose yeah that would
probably be my next step maybe read a
little bit more of the documentation we
were just reading I don't like to read a
lot of documentation on the stream this
I mean obviously it's not very fun to
watch see okay I am gonna commit this
even though it's not exactly working so
let's just say did my internet just cut
out
okay if the stream just cut out I'm
really sorry for that my internet just
completely stopped for a few seconds and
now it's back that's so that's the
second time today the internet just
completely cut out so I'm not sure
what's going on but sorry about that
alright let me now we've done to get ad
let's do yarn CM and a new feature not
the best can be message in the world but
it'll do for now
[Music]
you know what I have my Ethernet cable
unplugged from my computer because for
some reason I can't access the database
the old database with it plugged in so I
was doing data transfer and I never
plugged it back in so that's probably
why the Internet's not as good as it
normally is so I'll try to remember to
have it plugged in for tomorrow stream
okay so let me go back to the live chat
now and answer some questions this is
all but everything that I've done is now
on the master branch on github so if you
want to check it out please feel free to
check that out if you want to submit
pull requests that would be awesome
let's see or if you want to use the code
in any of your projects you know feel
free to do so so I'm gonna find out
where I left off here it is and for the
rest of the stream we're not really
going to do much coding unless I get a
question about the code what I'm just
going to go through do some questions
and answers and let's see
Leigha sue Kim says react is jazz
framework yes it is a JavaScript
framework
Leah sue Kim says so many files any
tutorial for learning file systems so
that wish free code camp had a tutorial
for that for newbies to think there
there is a basic Linux tutorial in a
basic get tutorial on Udacity and
they're both free and they're both very
short so it's easy to kind of go through
the tutorials in just a few hours so I
would recommend those so they're on you
the Udacity website
Oh Nicky says check out the beta free
code camp curriculum it might have a
tutorial yeah I don't know for sure if
it does or not I haven't checked it out
and a really really long time but there
may be something in there that's a good
thought we did have a question about the
theme in my theme and I'm using Visual
Studio code the theme is SETI SETI and
then for github it's the github dark
theme to probably have to google that
and it's a little bit of work to get it
working but it's not it's not really
that difficult just a few steps John
says needle in a haystack you've got a
good memory Jesse even when you're fuzzy
thank you thank God it just came to me
all of a sudden I so it kind of lucked
out there
Leah sue Kim says big companies div tags
are like sandwich inside each other it's
hard to define which one is which yeah
for sure for sure when the when the
actual markup is created by like a
program it there are quite a few divs in
there also asked by the way what is he
creating now it's a react website and in
this particular thing that we're
creating is a search page for that
website so we're getting data from the
WordPress REST API and we're pulling it
into this react site and you know doing
some sorting and filtering so that users
can get exactly what they're looking for
now Leah sue Kim s if free code camp has
back-end course in PHP I don't think we
have anything in PHP but again I really
don't know what's there in the beta
curriculum right now if I had to guess
I'd say there's not PHP if you want
something with PHP like a beginner
course check out code Academy they do
have some PHP courses I believe that
some free courses in PHP so that that
would be a good place to start for a
beginner level if you're past the
beginner level I don't I don't really
know what's the best PHP resources
let's see
mahmud says semicolon stiff yeah I don't
use semicolon but I'm okay if you want
to use semicolons that's totally cool I
don't hate on semicolon users Alexandre
is saying anybody who's using MongoDB I
wish to learn you know what we have
[ __ ] going and some of our other
projects and one of my side projects but
I I didn't do a lot of hands-on work
setting it up so I'm probably not the
one to to teach anything about [ __ ] at
this point I don't think Harsha is
watching it's too late in his time zone
but he knows about MongoDB so maybe in
the future stream someone named Harshit
might be in here Alexandre and he would
he'd be able to tell you a lot more
about [ __ ]
because I'm having a lot of questions
about editors and what tests editor are
using if my test editor you mean like
what I was testing with here this is
just dev tools but it has the dark theme
and then I was using the react dev tools
which is a separate I think it's a
plugin an extension that you can get so
you know that doesn't automatically come
with with Chrome and then you can just
go into the settings and click on dark
theme and it'll look like this
dishes I wish I had a more powerful
computer vs code and Chrome would work
just fine then simultaneously oh yeah I
guess I mean for my work computer it's
it's pretty good so I never noticed that
but yeah that probably could be an issue
though on older computers I wonder I
wonder is there another editor that
takes less I don't I don't know I mean I
would think Adam would be similar
I don't really know about sublime
whether Sublime's better or not
Sublime's not electron based so maybe it
would have better performance
Jim trader says do you think it matters
what platform someone learns to code on
Windows versus Mac I was told that most
employers provide Mac for their
employees and that it would benefit me
to learn on a Mac Jim trader I don't
think yeah I don't think it would make a
difference for me developing on Mac has
been easier because most of the
tutorials that I find assume that you
have access to like the Linux commands
so Mac or Linux would probably be
preferable but when I was learning on
Windows it was it was fun so I did I
mean I've been a developer for five
years maybe give or take a year and for
the first few years I was always on
Windows and then after that you know for
like maybe six months I was sometimes
windows sometimes Mac and then now for
the last two years at least
I've been predominantly like Mac all the
time I don't do any development on
Windows anymore yeah but I said the only
difference that I've seen has just been
the commands that I use
so I I don't think as long as you know
how to use a Mac it really doesn't take
that long to get used to the differences
so I wouldn't worry about that if anyone
else has a different experience than
that please let me know and let Jim
Schrader note
John says once you have the code inside
your editor I don't believe that matters
what your operating system is on your
machine yes I mean that that's for sure
I mean most of the which you do is going
to be inside the editor and you can use
the same editor on pretty much any
machine you know if you're using like
Adam or Visual Studio code so it should
be fine no matter what you're using
world's asked if I heard back from the
Pittsburgh job interview
yeah actually do you don't want an
update on that I can give you an update
on that now yeah why don't I just give
you an update now so I had I don't know
my Internet's cutting out again all
right let me give it a second before I
say anything all right it looks all
right now
so I had this interview a few weeks ago
it went well and about a a week week and
a half after the interview I got an
offer from this company so the offer was
pretty good it wasn't it wasn't quite as
much as I was expecting so I did a
little bit of you know talked with the
company let him know more of like what
what my salary expectations were and you
know like what I was basically like what
I was dealing with and why I expected a
higher salary you know just in terms of
you know my family my expenses and
things so they they were I'm still
waiting on some information so tomorrow
I should get more info back on exactly
what they can do in terms of
compensation to give me more than their
initial offer so I have not
made my final decision yet as to whether
I do want to work at this other place
it's it's going to depend on what
information I get tomorrow so basically
I have my numbers in mind of what it
would take for me to leave where I'm at
right now so if those numbers get met I
probably will leave otherwise I'll stay
I've already talked it over with my
family and so yeah at this point it's
just you know does it make financial
sense to move to go somewhere else or
not so we'll find out you know hopefully
tomorrow I will get the the info so they
said it would be tomorrow so I'm that's
what I'm gonna be able to make my final
decision but after the whole process is
over maybe I can make a little video and
explaining more what happened I just I
don't want to comment on it too much
while it's happening I think I'll have a
much better perspective on the whole
process once it's all done with and I'll
be able to give I don't like a much
better explanation of the the whole
thing
let's see
all right Julio says you can use
built-in get instead of the terminal way
I I guess you mean like they get stuff
built into Visual Studio code I've never
tried to use any of the stuff built into
Visual Studio code to be honest with you
I I just I mean when I learned get
initially I just learned all the command
line stuff and so I don't I really know
how to use the other stuff
I sing videos says what is the WordPress
REST API exactly okay so the WordPress
REST API is so you have your regular
WordPress installation so any of the
ones that are using the latest versions
of WordPress they're really any version
for I think at least the last year we'll
have the REST API built in so what you
can do is send a query to the REST API
and they'll give you data back in JSON
format right so it's just it works like
any REST API so you can get all you get
a bunch of data from from WordPress so
by default you can't get everything but
with the right plugins or you know
custom PHP you can pretty much get all
the data you want from WordPress so it
allows you to use WordPress as a content
management system without using the
display part of WordPress so WordPress
themes and and all that you can just get
the data out and use it wherever you
want on on other web sites that aren't
wordpress based let me know if that
explanation cleared things up for you I
can go kind of in more depth or show
some examples of the data if you need me
to the candy gamer extreme asks in your
opinion is it too late to start coding
after you join your uni or is it still
possible to make a good career oh yeah
it's never too late to start coding no
yeah I didn't start coding until after I
was done with uni and my wife's learning
to code right now and she's she didn't
start learning to code until she's 32
so yeah never too late to start learning
to code bark char so has just dropped in
how often do you stream I try to stream
Monday through Friday every day I don't
always get there but that's that's the
goal but for sure I usually stream you
know a few times a week at at least
Aniki says if you're really into editor
performance I guess them would take the
cake I didn't even think about them but
yeah I suppose them would probably be
the most performant one them was last
time I tried them I was I was a little
lost so I haven't tried it since then
I'd like to try it again at some point
I hear if you really do learn them it's
it's good for productivity so I would
I'd really need to take the time to get
to learn it first so maybe someday I
will
okay I'm under the bottom alright I
think up to the bottom there were a few
comments and things that I kind of
skipped over a bit mainly because there
are conversations back and forth me too
and other people in the chat but now
that you all who are watching this
recording can view the live chat as well
I'll probably not read off everything
like I did before that should help keep
the streams just a little bit shorter
maybe a little bit easier to follow
along with oh we did get one more
question corrington says hi Jesse what's
the font you're using in your text
editor I don't know let's find out where
we had settings/preferences
maybe settings yeah let's get rid of
this alright the font family is Menlo so
I'm assuming it's Menlo so there we are
does anyone have a font that they really
think is better for for coding
I'm opening I mean I know that's gonna
have a huge difference in readability
and things so I'm definitely open to
changing changing things up yeah no
problem course and then let me know if
I'm mispronouncing the name that name I
want to get it right if I can all right
so I see icing video says thank you for
that answer about WordPress api's would
you be able to use any API available at
Google etc thanks for helpful oh yeah
for sure you can use any API you want
from from reacts or from a lot of other
things for that matter but yeah we could
pull in from wherever we need to get the
data from and the process would be
somewhat similar right you know all API
is have their differences in how you're
supposed to use them but you know it
basically making the calls fetching the
data getting back JSON format and then
filtering and sorting that and
displaying it on the page that that's
going to be the same no matter where
you're getting the data from
okay so fire a code with ligatures all
right is that is that a font is that a
font that's like well-known enough that
I could just use it let's see where did
it take my stuff copy the settings there
we are
so can I do
so would it work like that is that the
name can I get it to work or what I have
to like bring it in somehow need to
download it okay so maybe I need to
download that what was the other one
console us so John says try consoles I'm
gonna leave that there in case I
download it then it might it might work
so let's leave that there is the first
one and then we'll do ok cool for this
one let's check it out huh oh I like
that I might try this out for a little
while then
no-no-no that changes things okay so I
can get I can get fire code on github
okay cool I'll have to try that out
maybe let's just check it out right now
this this will probably the last thing
we do on the stream but if I don't do it
right now I'll probably forget cuz I
don't feel a lot I'm probably gonna go
home right after this maybe I can get it
on vs code right away cool alright oh
cool sure
see
cool alright so let's try it I need to
let's go back here but I still I'm open
huh yeah all right so let's change it up
to fire code and I need I need to add
these so those it's all together and
then what was that ligatures they're
gonna let me just change this editor
font like it sure is true
okay so yeah it doesn't look like it
works what am I missing
does work you can try restarting it or
wrapping it let's make sure I wrap that
properly yeah the kitchen I restarting
maybe I can try that then yeah let's
restart yeah I got an update coming
anyway so I was well retry okay
nikki says the ligatures make things
like like the arrow function look like
an actual arrow that's cool very cool
okay nikki says check out the
installation instructions so let's see
now that i happily get yours on alright
so not yet alright let me go back to the
installation instructions then cool
I will download this first I don't
install on a Mac
oh I can just do home bro let's do that
yeah let's just run home bro all right
cool
now that's not supported all right fine
I'll just do it this way just like the
old phone calls right-click and select
open go select install font okay cool
what just happened no this is not what I
wanted to happen
all right there's instructions all files
right click open select install flaunt
that is not what just happened when I
followed this instructions I think like
this is not how I normally install fonts
alright let's open a new Finder window
alright I got my stuff my windows open
on another page so that's why I'm not
seeing that much happening so all right
so on a Mac download it right there's
another way for sure to do this right
isn't there a fonts folder
all right insult etfs then it is going
to work okay cool that's what I just did
I'll tell you my angel t-shirt all right
cool so I took the TTF file so I'll put
them in the font folder so let's see
what happened wait is this it is this
working huh yay cool all right so just
just to show you all what I needed to do
when I do my other screen so am i Mac I
have like under my username I went into
library which is a hidden folder and
then the fonts' and then I just drove
over so I downloaded
there were several files that came up so
one of them was the TTF file so I just
grabbed everything that's in the TTF
file and then I drug it over to here and
then it just started working so you can
see I've done this before with fonts
which didn't remember I did it
so all the Roboto stuff that I have in
here materiai cons and things like that
are in here already
alright cool that that looks really cool
Wow yeah a lot of stuff looks yeah you
can definitely tell the difference
awesome
very cool all right
all right well I think that's it for the
stream so I hope that I don't get even
more sick than I am right now and that I
will come to work tomorrow and be able
to strain if I can't strain tomorrow
then you probably know where I'm at I'm
home in bed
but I will most likely be able to stream
at my big normal time tomorrow I don't
think I have a lot going on so I'll
probably be around noon sometime thank
you all so much for watching and for
helping out for all your advice and for
helping each other out in the live chat
it was some great questions and answers
today and yeah so see y'all tomorrow and
until then have a wonderful day